- I'm in New York, I can't
do this (bleeped out) alone,
so to help me introduce
tonight's hashtag
we have a very special guest,
please welcome Ben Stiller!
(crowd cheering)
Hey Ben.
Ben Stiller!
Thank you so much, it's
so good to see you.
(crowd cheering)
You got it, good.
Ben thank you.
- The worst thing to do
- Well you gotta,
it's Ben Stiller.
Thank you so much
for coming man.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
it's great to be here.
(audience laughs)
I'm sorry, um.
- [Chris] What's wrong?
This isn't Fallon is it?
(audience laughs)
- No, did ping pong
balls fall on you?
Is someone singing Karaoke?
No this is.
It's at midnight.
- Okay, I'm sorry, it's just,
like, crazy whirlwind
day and I just thought
this was Fallon and I was like
what the hell
happened to the roots?
(audience laughs)
- I'm not Questlove.
I'm not Quest, I look like him.
- But I'm sure you guys
are probably a great band.
- No they're comedians actually,
that's Jim Gaffigan and
Mike Black and Kyle.
(audience laughs)
Have you not actually
seen the show?
Have you seen the program?
- What? What, no
I've seen the show.
- [Chris] Okay, good.
- I love a midnight.
- No.
(audience laughs)
It's an at symbol, at
midnight, it's at midnight.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah and
I love the whole thing
you do, every night, that
thing with the thing.
- Yeah, yeah, I know,
you mean the hashtag war.
- Yes, the hash bag
ward, I love it.
- Good
- It's so good I never miss it
- Then great, since
you're here then,
would you please introduce
the hash bag ward?
- Actually, you know what,
I've got a thing that
I gotta run to so,
sorry, I gotta.
- Okay, wait
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- Before you go, is
there something that
you wanted to at least promote
since you took the time to.
- No
(audience laughs)
I was literally just walking
by and I thought this,
anyway, it's great
seeing you buddy.
- Do you actually
even know my name?
- Yes, I know your name.
I know your name, I know
that you're who you are.
- [Chris] Uh huh, which is?
- Not Jimmy Fallon.
- Not Jimmy, so that would
mean that logically I'm.
- Yes, you're Seth.
- Seth Myers, yeah,
I'm Seth Myers.
(audience laughs)
- Let me tell you something man.
Honestly, I have not
watched SNL since you left.
- Oh I appreciate
that, thank you.
Ben Stiller everyone.
(audience applauds)